[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in uh tom curran
he's a patriots insider nbc
sports boston let me start with the
snarky poll question who feels worse
today
bill belichick or robert kraft bill
belichick
and he should he's the one who didn't
know what he was looking at
over the last five years and the guy was
standing right in front of him
so now he's mining the draft
and mid-tier free agents to find a
replacement that'll pay more than he was
willing to pay the guy
who won the super bowl craft at least
dan said we'd really like to have him
stay
but i i was wondering about that that he
and maybe this is credit to robert craft
that he
allows his coaches to coach or you know
he gets out of the way
but at some point it's your team that he
never thought of big footing bill
belichick to say
i can't let tom brady play in another
uniform
and i think that bill convinced him that
the trepidation of a guy at 43 years old
robert what are we going to do we're
going to pay him this much money
and if he starts to go over the cliff
then what and robert had to look at it
and say look
who's easier to replace the quarterback
that i think bill can
do because i saw him do it in 2008 with
matt castle
or replace bill and his scouting staff
and his coaching and the special teams
acumen and everything else the easier
thing to do
is say goodbye to the 43 year old as
much as it tears my heart out
if i would have told you 11 months ago
this was going to be the result what
would you said
it wouldn't shock me i mean at the
beginning of the year i said that tampa
would win the super bowl they would go
13-3 and win the super bowl
and it's because of how good tampa kinda
was
i mean they were seven and nine last
year their quarterback threw 30 picks
they lost six games i think it was by a
touchdown or less
just bring somebody in with a level of
competency and you're going to be good
bring the best there's ever been who can
infuse discipline into everybody
you're going to be really freaking good
so i wouldn't have been surprised dan
you know the last two weeks brady has
taken the high road when it comes to
bill belichick like
verbal bouquets and like what do you
think he really feels about
how this ended his relationship with
belichick because
he he said what you would want him to
say so he didn't draw any more attention
to this
you know fractured relationship i think
he imagines now or feels now that this
is for the best and he's not looking
back
and for us who we're continuing to chase
the car like a bunch of dogs
nipping at the bumper he's just driving
along he doesn't even know we're back
there
i mean he has moved on and i think it's
one of those things
there is there is a whole different
world out here that i can enjoy and do
things differently and
i think it was painful as hell for him
but bill kind of made it easy to divorce
himself from new england
by allowing him to picture himself
someplace else you know i'm telling a
story in the column i'm writing about
how i sat with guerrero alex guerrero
last year two days
before the super bowl we were flying out
of miami and i was looking back at some
of the notes i took
and what guerrero had said at that time
january 31st 2020
all he wants is the coach
to signal that he wants him to stay
that's all he wanted
but he never got that and never did
yeah if you look at the accomplishments
for brady where does last night rank
to me dan it's a validation it's uh
you know i think 28 to 3 is greater
i think that the super bowl in 2014 was
more high level football
but i think this is a validation he he
is now the greatest team sports
performer
in pro sports history he's not the
greatest athlete
i don't even know if he's the greatest
football player of all time because you
still have jerry rice sitting out there
with some absurd numbers
but he trumps jordan and russell and
gretzky
as the greatest team sports performer
able to go
into a 53-man roster an 80-man team with
coaches and infuse it it's not
basketball like lebron jordan
it's one guy impacting almost 100 people
and what i i've said all morning long is
that there is
if you're a young player you just look
at him he's the most animated
he's you know in people's faces whether
it's the opponents or you
he there's accountability you know it's
what you want in a leader
you know he doesn't play at a high level
the way he once did
but that confidence level i don't think
can be understated
certainly for a team that was probably
impressionable like
tampa was uh that they were looking for
something they were looking that if
things go bad
he's not letting us go you know south
and i i you know there's something to be
said about that in his ability to lead
you know i wonder what those days were
like after he had the four fingers up
and confused the downs
i mean that's if jameis winston does
that or
nick foles or whoever
i mean the whole team probably is like
oh my god and there were probably guys
looking at brady and go this guy's
i mean come on he's screaming at us he
can't get the downs right yeah
but whatever it is that he does to
infuse that
team with don't worry about it i got it
it's amazing and
and you talk about the performance it is
the same as it's always been dan it's
it's whatever you need if you need
505 against philadelphia to give you a
shot
he'll do that if you need what he brings
to get 28.3 he'll do that
if it's five for nine for 60 yards in
the second half last night fine that's
fine too
uh you created some headlines saying
that matthew stafford did not want to go
to new england uh recap that story and
was there any fallout
after that report
i was told sunday
hours after stafford had agreed to go to
los angeles that a team
in negotiations with detroit was told
that stafford was willing to really go
anywhere but new england he had said i
don't want to go to new england so that
was noteworthy the person thought who
had been in negotiations to share with
me
the fallout i think was interesting
because
to me it legitimized what we
look at the patriots post brady as being
it's a team in
rebuild mode and it's a team that's not
a lot of fun to play for
it's a team that talks about no days off
when you're 33 you want some days off
i mean that's not a picnic to come up
into the northeast you're matthew
stafford you've been playing inside
you're 33 years old you haven't won
anything and you're gonna go
rebuild in the cold and play in buffalo
and the meadowlands
whatever it is uh it doesn't sound like
a good time and that's why i think it's
hard for the patriots to
you know say we are who we were when
brady was here
also he had the gronk situation that he
chose retirement
over possibly playing again i guess with
the patriots if they wanted him back
just the fact that he he could have fun
that
freeing feeling i guess um
does that surprise you though that gronk
wanted to come back but only wanted to
come back if he's going to have fun and
play with brady
no because in 2018 before they won their
final super bowl the patriots were
trying to trade gronk to detroit i mean
that was damaging to him and then they
spent that whole season
i mean he was mentally wracked by
uncertainty about whether he could play
where his body was at
and you know as he explained to me at
the super bowl
you're doing things to your body that
are unnatural
and they keep asking you every week to
go out and practice all week and do it
again on sunday
i mean he wanted to be managed at that
point he felt his body was so beat up
that he wanted to have himself managed
in a different way and the patriots were
not
you know acceding to that and that's
where bill
is everybody's on the same level
everybody's on the same plane
no special favors especially for guys
who are making 15 million dollars or 12
million dollars
but there comes a point where you're the
point you're trying to make
is gonna lose some people i also
wondered about this and that is
if i'm new england if i'm bill belichick
how do i
and not that he's competing with tom
brady but if i want to re-energize
this franchise can they go all in and
get to sean watson
i think desean watson is going to be the
same mind that matthew stafford was and
that is i
i don't want to go and honestly too dan
think about this
in this age of players who are making so
much money especially in the nfl and
finding their voices in a way that they
haven't previously
clearly desean watson is most pissed off
because they didn't get much seat at the
table to
to converse there's not a seat at the
table you're not even in the room
in new england so he's not going to want
to come up here and just you know be a
work at a guy hitting the
punch punching his time clock every day
and coming in and leaving he wants to be
in there belichick's gonna cool
but but brady never had any input on
personnel decisions in new england at
all
nope no one does the personnel guys
barely do
[Laughter]
and then here he is he should get gm
votes uh
gm of the year with what he did in tampa
that you get in
he he recruits antonio brown somehow
gets him leonard fournette comes in and
gronk comes in and all three scored
touchdowns last night
i mean it's wild it it really is to see
you know that performance and it's funny
because throughout these playoffs dan i
think there's been this
pushback that brady is carrying the
buccaneers it's tom brady and
he just did what was necessary he staked
the team to a lead against the packers
played
played fine you know the picks in the
second half people took that as a
smoking gun that he's not very good
you know same thing with new orleans it
was the way they undressed
drew brees it wasn't brady and i think
it was a straw man argument no one was
saying that tom brady was out there
putting up triple doubles he was just
playing the game as it needed to be
played in the postseason which is kind
of what he's always done
do you think belichick watched the game
last night
boy that's a great question i would
imagine he probably did
i i would imagine he probably did
when do you uh see belichick again
when's the media
get in front of belichick to ask that
question yeah normally it would be
at the owner's meetings at the end of
march but i would see
the the chance of that happening are
very slim
so probably not until a pre-draft
audience that he gives us because i
can't imagine he's going to ring us up
and see how we're all doing
i just don't see that coming down the
line will you ask that question if given
the opportunity
would you send me a coffee if i did yes
done
all right that's easy it's a lot it's an
extra large hot coconut with
milk and three splenda oh three splint
okay all right
yeah all right i'll take care of it it
might be a little cold by the time it
gets to you but it will get to you
fair enough thank you tom
good to talk to you buddy all right
enjoy the rest of your year that's tom e
curran patriots insider for nbc sports
boston who joins us on the program